hi I'm Chris Wilson from grinding Gear
games welcome to the build of the week a
weekly video series where we showcase a
path of Excel character build designed
by a community member one of the most
popular builds that emerged from the
recent one point one point faith patch
was the combination of some and raging
spirit and spell echo there are several
variations of this build but we chose to
demonstrate this one because it has a
really interesting choice of unique
weapon choba choba at grinding Gear
games we love skulls especially those
that are on fire this build used to
spell echo and it stacks a lot of cast
speed to summon a swarm of raging
spirits that seek out enemies it also
animates every weapon that drops to
provide some additional damage and to
keep monsters occupied its first primary
skill summon raging spirit is supported
by level 21 corrupted faster casting
merely physical damage mill a splash
spell echo and added fire damage animate
weapon is support of a multi strike
increased duration weapon elemental
damage and melee splash these gems are
all placed in a choba choba which is a
very interesting choice of weapon is
generally thought of as a weapon for
conversion straight characters but it
works very well in this build both of
the primary skills adoration Bound and
benefit from this 15% bonus the maximum
mana mod helps synergize with eldritch
battery the additional skill levels
improve most of the gems used in this
item alphas howl is used to house auras
because of the bonuses we've covered
before in previous videos the build runs
five or is in total of benefit as
minions and himself this makes him
popular with parties the auras are Roth
anger haste discipline and clarity flesh
offering is used to increase the
movement and attack speed of the minions
convocation allows the animated weapons
to be positioned at will
the build uses two armor types that have
energy shield which is turned into mana
by eldritch battery there's a trade-off
between using armor slots for free mana
or important defenses defensively the
build uses Arctic honor and the
distraction of a swarm of animated
weapons distance is an important
defensive tool it's possible to play
incredibly carefully with us build the
passive skill tree starts as a Sion and
spreads out from there mana mana
regeneration and cast speed have been
picked up to help with a primary goal of
casting a lot of raging spirits quickly
eldritch battery is the only Keystone
passive used
converting all of the characters energy
shoulder to mana allows it to cast an
unlimited number of raging spirits while
running 5 or as and Arctic armor all
from its mana pool only offensive minion
notes
chosen because raging spirits don't
benefit from defensive bonuses animated
weapons do but this bill doesn't rely on
them taking much damage this is the
deceptively strong build it runs the
highest levels of Maps they can do so in
relative safety by utilizing the full
range of raging spirits as possible to
kill most monsters without ever having
to get close to them the build is an
interesting alternate style of summoner
because it focuses on duration based
minions rather than the indefinite tanky
ones like zombies the author comments
that some bosses or rogue a excels are
hard unless you have animated weapons up
because monsters don't target the raging
spirits this was the final episode of
season 2 of build of the week don't
worry though the series will return with
season 3 when we release the expansion
in August keep posting and maintaining
your build guides and their class forums
on path of excel combo will select some
of the most interesting builds to
showcase next season as always thanks
for watching